are you ready to learn how to make a
super short end or ninja star frisbee
this model that I have here made out of
the single sided ninja stars is a model
I pretty much came up with myself I
didn't learn this anywhere and I don't
think you're going to find any other
tutorials online showing you how to
interlock the single sided ninja stars
now before you watch the rest of this
tutorial I need you guys to first know
how to make the single sided ninja star
so if you haven't seen my tutorial for
that you can click this little button or
link up here and that will show you how
to make the ninja star so that you can
interlock it to make this super shuriken
so being that this is a model that I
came up with myself it's not necessarily
the best model there are other ways to
make ninja star frisbees that you might
find online but I don't think you're
going to find any that show you how to
interlock the single sided ninja stars
most of the tutorials online for making
ninja stars in general are on how to
make the double sided ninja stars which
I also now have a tutorial for that you
can click this link up here and it will
take you to that tutorial also so once
you have six single sided ninja stars
that look something like this you're
ready to go on and make this super
shuriken before you go on to try to
interlock the ninja stars just please
make sure that they all look about the
same they should be nearly identical and
they should all be neatly folded and
interlocked properly and look something
like these now when you look at the back
of the ninja star you'll notice that
this back piece creates what looks like
a sleeve on the back here and the back
piece also has pockets there's one
pocket here on the right and there's
another pocket here on the left and
these pockets and sleeves allow you to
slide other ninja star tips inside each
other to create a whole bunch of
different models or design so there's
pretty much an endless possibility of
ways you can connect these things so the
way that we're going to interlock them
to create the super shuriken with the
six ninja stars is we're going to first
flip all of the ninja stars over so that
we have the back side facing towards us
okay so it's going to make things easier
if you arrange your ninja stars and
position them like I have here as you'll
see the back part the back piece here is
slanted to the left so it's not being
held like this where it's slanted to the
right I want you to position them so
they're all slanted to the left like
they are here then you could pick up
your next ninja star and you want to
hold it next to the first one as you'll
see I have them number here so you want
to hold the second ninja star next to
the first one in the same position and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to take the tip of the second star
and we're going to slide it into the
sleeve on the left side of the first one
so you're holding them like this and
we're just going to rotate the second
one and this is going to slide in there
when you do that you'll see that the
bottom of this ninja star point is
aligning with this one here and also
when you slide them in you'll see that
these two tips also meet up okay so we
took them and we just live that in there
just like that then take the next one
and it should be held the same way that
this is slanted to the left and then you
can take the tip of this star and you
could slide it in there the same exact
way okay so there we have three
connected and we take the fourth one do
the same thing just slide it in there
okay then take the fifth one and slide
it in just like that okay so if you fit
everything together properly then the
point of the fifth ninja star here
should be directly above the point of
the first ninja star here and if you'll
see there is a little bit of a pocket on
this tip here of the fifth ninja star so
if you just slide it back a little bit
you'll see that the tip of the first one
can actually slide into that little
pocket there on the fifth one so all you
need to do to just take that tip and
just make sure that it goes in that
little pocket and that will keep your
ninja star pretty stable it can still
come apart but that will hold it
together a little bit better okay so you
should have a model that looks something
like this and we're going to take the
last ninja star and you want to hold it
the same way that we've been doing where
this is slanted to the left like that
and then we're just going to slide this
tip here into the sleeve on the fifth
ninja star the same way that we've been
doing so just hold it like that and
slide it in and as you'll see the last
point that we have here for the sixth
ninja star is positioned above the
pocket here on the left of the first
ninja star so all we need to do is to
open up that pocket there you might need
to stick a pencil tip in there just to
make sure it's wide enough and then
you'll see you should be able to slide
this last point of the six ninja star
into that open pocket and it's not going
to fit together perfectly there might be
a little bit of a space here but it will
hold your super Cherie 10 together so
there you go you have finished this
super shuriken all right so if you're
going to throw it just know that these
things are not made to withstand being
thrown at super high speeds it can stay
together for about one throw and then it
will probably come apart if not come
apart while while you're throwing it and
just shoot six ninja stars across the
room at once but what you want to do is
just fling it like a frisbee and
as you'll see kinda came over here and
hit my chair and did break into a bunch
of pieces but it did fly pretty well and
all you need to do now just reconnect
everything if you really want it to stay
together then you can just put a little
bit of tape